you produce a show called who do you
think you are
yes okay and in which you find it's a
really great show and you this research
team that does an amazing job of finding
out all about celebrities and their
ancestors right you asked me would I be
interested in doing it I said sure okay
and they said spit in a cup you know for
your for your DNA yeah I did what was
the police want that too but I so I did
that and then they said tell us a little
bit about your family yeah so I did and
they said we'll get back to you with
amazing things about your past yes they
did
I've never heard from them that was a
year ago right it was a year ago yeah
yeah what's going on it's your tough
Irish ancestry is really tough though
because I would say it whatever you're
going to say because of you know of your
family Kate you know everything about
your family here okay
so right right the whole point was to
find out what were they up to in Ireland
right yeah but nobody knows anything
okay but you all have the same name
see I could have told you that I tried
to tell your people you're wasting your
time the minute you get to Ireland no
one's keeping records everyone's like
liar it's just gonna be craziness I know
but sometimes you find people in like
prison records or howdy whorehouse or
poorhouse O'Brien's were hanging out
[Laughter]
yeah yeah okay I'm gonna cut you off
right there and let the lawsuits begin
hey thanks for watching be sure to click
subscribe to see even more great Conan
clips you may now return to your pirated
movies and creepy Japanese pornography